what you're saying is
just because scaring people into god
works
puts butts in seats right as richard
would say it also keeps the clergy
employed right because we need you to
clean us yeah
every week
unless it unless you can kind of
you know like i think the it was the
gospel on sunday
where it's uh
you know
the rich guy who kind of builds the
tower to hold all his grain and
everything and then they go what a fool
you know because tonight you're gonna
die yeah and now what good is it yeah
and so so jesus sells that parable but
the last line so many that are like
they're like chris rock jokes yeah they
really are yeah that's kind of that's
fierce it is but the last line is about
uh
you know growing rich in the things that
matter to god so you know so i'm
preaching on that i don't care about all
that this isn't about bank accounts
this is about growing rich so if you
kind of distill the thing
it says cut that [__] out don't be
greedy don't you know
stop that
but the last line is about
growing rich in the things that matter
well that's the thing i'm gonna that's
the invitation so fine my insight was
find the invitation because it's always
inviting you to joy not to cut that [__]
out you know and and so you want to find
the joy
you know if people people think that
being a christian for example is like
some grim duty
but
but it's really kind of where the joy is
at least for me yeah you know at the
margins with folks who are struggling
you go wow this must be hard i go no
it's where the joy is that's i feel
i feel kind of selfish
i i believe you and if there's anything
i can offer you that's unique for me as
i was just at a
smoke-blowing
festival
where you blow smoke up my ass i blow
smoke up your ass and we all walk around
as ramdas would say i say i see your
outfit i see your disguise and i
validate that it's real do you see my
disguise and validate that it's real
yeah we all just go around telling each
other that our our masks are on straight
and you really are pete homes and i go
and you really are that and here's an
award or like and here's a special
headlining gala or whatever it is yeah
and i just want to not you don't seem to
need encouragement but i believe
everybody enjoys it
it doesn't it doesn't work i'm not
saying
i i can
it's a paradox on one hand i'm so
grateful that i get to do something so
so rare
and so uniquely lined up with my talents
being comedy but on the in the other
hand i'm going like
uh i think in the same verse jesus says
don't store your treasure where moth and
rust can corrupt
so the real the real [__] the real [__]
and i get
intoxicated i get seduced
like salt and light flavor and
illumination like these are
sexy things these are
alluring things and when i get them and
when you know them when you hear them
i'm saying like
the the
it's not just a duty spirituality it
actually it actually makes me start
inflating again because i was just at a
place where all we were doing was
you know filling up a silo
when we were gonna die that night yeah
but it's also your gift you know and so
i i you're not diminishing yourself no
no no because you understand you know
and then how necessary it is for people
to laugh and to kind of be lost in some
kind of
moment where you just say well that was
a you know a good
use of my time yes but then there's all
the other stuff that well i'm talking
about the badges and the who said what
to me and yeah it's a real orgy of that
it's it's tough it's
tough i so richard has a line where he
goes
life isn't about you you are about life
yeah and i every morning i would say the
festival's not about me i'm about the
festival i'm one of the co-creators of
this
joyful thing that people need and all
that stuff but if i didn't take that
moment i know that the depression you
get we actually kind of become immune
and someone could go you're the greatest
thing in the world you don't even feel
it yeah so
enough about me
i'd love to hear you talk a little bit
about what
what is the real treasure what is the
pearl of great price and all that and
how do you
identify it and how do you commune with
it yeah i don't know if it's if it's the
same for everybody you know i mean it's
it's how do you
it's
what is same i think is
you know
to find your true self and loving and
then then you love being loving so it's
not about return it's not about if
anybody loves you back then you don't
even care because that's the kind of god
we have who could give two shits whether
you love them back we don't we don't
believe that because our dna says
i'm a bad boy yeah and it also says that
god says uh
as i have loved you love me back
though you won't find that anywhere
really yeah god says as i have loved you
so must you have a special preferential
care and love for the widow orphan and
the stranger it's so
not
what we expect yeah you know it's about
loving folks who are
who the world says
we can live without you
and and so then you kind of go wow
that's the kind of god we have that's
the kind of love i want to be
and then you you try it on for size and
you go wow this is
this is the most joy i've ever known
[Music]